How's it going everyone? In this video,
we are going to talk about relevant
highs and lows or where to look for
reversals to form. Now, if you haven't
already seen my video on failure swings,
please go ahead and check that out first
is you need to understand this before
you understand this video. But let's get
into the PDF. So the first thing you
need to understand is what is a swing
point and you can see we have a bullish
swing point and a bearish swing point
here. A bullish swing point is a candle
that has a low and then a higher low to
its right and to its left and that is
what creates a bullish swing point. Now
a bearish swing point has a high and
then a lower high to its left and right
creating a bearish swing point. Now what
are relevant highs and lows? Well, those
are swing points that are actually
relevant. And so when we have failure
swings, and that's why it's important to
understand that concept, these are not
relevant highs because we are not
expecting a reversal right here. If
price trades into this level, we're not
expecting a reverse right here because
there are still highs to its left. So we
go find the extreme and that is our
relevant swing high. And similarly on
this side here, if price was to reverse
right here, right? That's not relevant
to us because it's so close to this low
that we're expecting it to go trade into
this low. So it's not relevant. Not
relevant. This extreme or this lowest
low is the relevant swing low. Now
relevant swing highs and relevant swing
lows are where we can look for reactions
or reversals in the market. When price
trades into these levels, we want to see
how price trades. Does it form a
manipulation or does it form a breakout
which we will talk about at the end of
this PDF. Now the next thing we want to
talk about is the valid separation in
what determines a relevant swing versus
a failure swing. When we have price
forming a low very close to its previous
low, that is not enough separation to
consider this a relevant swing. If price
is to trade into this level, I'm not
really expecting it to reverse and trade
away from it without taking out this low
or I would not personally trust it.
Versus over in this example, this is
valid separation, right? We have quite a
bit of range to that previous low. When
price trades into this level, if we do
get a reaction, this is something I
could consider to trade away from as
it's not close enough to this low to not
let me trust it. So, you can see we get
a nice reaction here versus in this
area, right? we kind of fail to form a
reaction here because we haven't hit
that relevant low yet. Now, when we have
a reaction at a relevant high or low,
what am I looking for? Well, I'm going
to be looking for a candle 2 or candle 3
closure. And with that, I'm going to be
using the wick or the EQ to look for
that candle 3 to respect, which I have
multiple videos about. And then the next
thing is the look back period. At what
point does a swing high or a low or a
relevant high and low become no longer
relevant because it occurred too far
into the past? And that is what I use my
higher time frame candles for. I'm going
to look in our current higher time frame
and then back two candles and I will use
highs and lows in that area and consider
them relevant. And this is a way I've
used to fractalize this concept and not
just use it on the daily chart. So, I'm
not just looking back 3 days, but it
could be 3 months, it could be three
hourly candles, but it's always going to
be that same look back period of three
higher time frame candles, including the
current one. Now, like I said, what is
the difference between a breakout and a
manipulation when we trade into a
relevant swing? I want to look at the
phases of price at that relevant swing.
Do we get a retracement, a reversal, or
a consolidation? Here you can see, do we
get a reversal? No. But then it's more
than likely a continuation here. We
retrace into a previous high or into
this previous daily high and then we
form a continuation lower versus at this
high here. Do we form a continuation or
a breakout? No. We form a reversal and
then we can trade to the other side of
the range. Let's get into trading view
and go over a few examples of relevant
swings and the reactions that occur at
them. So here we are in Trading View and
let's talk about relevant swings and
failure swings. So let's take a look and
we'll just go ahead and mark out our
previous highs and lows. So we'll start
with the lows and if you notice we have
these stacked lows here, right? And you
can see this one basically exactly equal
and we have there. So just looking at
this sell side here, what low is
relevant here? If price was to come down
into this level, would I want to trade
away from this low or do I not trust
that as it's so close to this low? And
then if I trade into this low, would I
want to trade away from that or higher
or do I not trust it because there's
equal lows right below? And then would I
want to trade away from these lows
without this one being taken out? No.
Right? So you probably said no to all of
those. And that's because this is the
relevant low. I don't trust trading away
from these lows below me. So I need to
wait for this relevant low to get taken
out. Now the upside here is a little bit
more complex, right? We trade into this
high and this is actually a high I would
consider relevant because it has pretty
good separation from this high. You can
see a pretty decent range from that
high. So I'd consider this relevant. Now
when price doesn't reverse off of this,
that is when this becomes the relevant
high. So now you can see we're basically
we have two relevant swings in the
market in which we're looking for price
to trade off of. So here you see now we
trade into a relevant swing. This is
where I want to look for a fractal
model, right? And now we have a candle
to closure. And where could we look to
trade to? Back to the other side of the
range or to those failure swings. Now,
taking a look here, would I want to
trade back higher here? Right? No,
because this is not a relevant swing.
It's so close to this one that I could
not trust myself to trade away from that
low. So, I would only be interested in
the short side. And there you can see
now we reach into a relevant low. Now
this is where I could be looking for a
reaction because it is relevant in the
market and you can see we go trade
lower. Now when we get this retracement
this becomes a relevant low right and
you continue to track those. Here we
have a high. We have good separation
between the previous high. Now this is a
relevant high in the market right and we
need to have a new low. So what do we
have? Just a continuation lower. We'll
let this speed along and then we trade
higher here. Now, where would we be
looking for a reversal? Do we want to
see price reverse off of this gap right
here? Not really, cuz we're so close to
this high. This is relevant in the
market. So, what do we have? We take out
that high. Now, where is our relevant
highs and lows? We have one here, and
then we have one right here. So, those
are where we want to be focused on
trading back into the range or the other
direction.
So right here now is this a relevant
low? Yes. Why is it? There is a lot of
separation between the previous low. So
I could look for a reaction at this
level. Right now we get a bunch of
consolidation here. So I'm just going to
speed through it. And if you haven't
noticed, this is oil on the daily chart.
So we'll notice what are we doing? We
are building failure swings. Now you
notice these are all relevant lows,
right? And we get little reactions at
them. What do we notice about the highs
here? These are all failure swings,
right? Would you trust trading short off
of this high, leaving this one? Probably
not, right? This one has a bit of
separation between those, but they are
still failure swings. So, I wouldn't
want to see all of these be taken out.
So, thus, this is my relevant high.
And we'll let this speed along.
And there we go. Finally hit into our
relevant low. Now, this is where we
could be looking for a reversal to form.
And where do we want to trade back to?
Well, relevant highs, right? And would I
trust this high to trade away from? No.
Because I have this failure swing, this
failure swing, this failure swing. So,
failure swings are those stacked highs,
right? That stacked liquidity. And
that's what we want to target. And we
want to have high resistance liquidity
or no failure swings on our stop-loss
side of the market, right? We get an
expansion. Now, would I want to trade
away from here? No, because we are
leaving this high right here, right? And
this is a fair value gap which is a high
on a lower time frame. But I would not
want to trade away from that.
And we went a little quick there. This
would be a relevant low. Why? Because
there is separation, right? Is this a
relevant low? Yes, but is a little bit
sketchy because we are so close to this
low. But I wouldn't want to trade away
from that until when? After we close
through and confirm this low. So now we
trade higher. Would I trust a reversal
if it forms here? No. I'm wanting to see
price reach into that relevant high. So,
just leaving that, would I anticipate a
reversal to form here? No. Not without
SMT. So, I'm viewing this as a
retracement. And do we want to see us
reach for this relevant low? Not if
we're bullish, right? So, that's where
we want to see this hold up. And what do
we see here? We run out this low here.
Now, is this a relevant low? Yes, it is.
Why? because there is a lot of
separation between the previous low and
it so it's relevant for price to form a
reversal off of right and we can trade
away from and so then we form these
highs and then we expand into that level
there now how do I combine this with the
fractal model well I'm going to go ahead
and add my indicator here and the way I
use it is I'm going to be focusing on
those relevant highs and lows that are a
higher time frame higher low so if you
notice this relevant swing low here was
also a monthly low. This relevant high
here is a monthly high. These are
relevant to me because they are a higher
time frame level. Now, in terms of look
back or how far back I'm looking, I'm
just going to be looking back at those
three months, right? Or three higher
time frame candles. It's months in this
case cuz we're on the daily chart. So, I
look back 1 2 3. These are where I'm
focused on finding my relevant highs and
lows. Generally speaking, that's what's
going to give the best reactions. Yes,
we can look at these even though they
are further back, but the three months
is what I'm looking for, that
three-month look back. Now, if I go to
an hourly chart here, how far am I going
to look back? Well, I'm going to look
back 3 days because that is my look
back, right? 1 2 3. So, that is my look
back period. It is fractal. And relevant
swings are where I look for my model to
form in the market. I don't want to just
look at random highs or lows. So, here
we are with one final example and let's
practice marking out our relevant highs
or lows. So, taking a look at the high
here, what do we have? We have equal
highs or failure swings, right? So, this
would be the relevant high. This is the
failure swing. Now, let's take a look at
our lows. We have a low right here. That
would be relevant. Now, what about this
low? Is this low relevant? Yes, it's a
failure swing technically, but look at
the separation it has between this low.
That's what makes it relevant. We can
expect price to trade into here and if
we form a reversal, we can trust it
because it's so far away from this low.
Now, let's say for example, instead
price had a low that looked like this.
Would we trust this low here? Probably
not because it's so close to this
previous low. There's not enough valid
separation for me to trust trading away
from this low but not having that one
being taken out. So removing those.
Let's continue with this and see what
happens. Right?
We have a little consolidation once
again. Now we have failure swings here.
Would we trust trading away from one of
these highs here? Probably not. Right?
Why is it? Well, yes, we take them all
out, but what are we leaving these
previous highs here? So, if you notice,
these aren't very relevant in the market
because they're so close to the previous
that this is our focus. So, we take a
look. I went too quick through it, but
we do form a reversal off this low. Why
is that relevant? Because it has valid
separation to this low. Now, I don't
have a mechanical reason to say, hey,
this is valid separation. That just
comes with experience and really the
discernment of looking at it and saying,
yeah, it's far enough away from this
low. So, taking a look, let's see. we
wouldn't want to trade this lower. And
now we go trade through this high. So
you can see how we form these relevant
swings in the market. And that's where
we want to focus on a point of interest
for using highs or lows. Now, I hope you
enjoyed this video. I know that's a
short examples, but I hope you go into
the charts and practice this because at
the end of the day, to learn this, you
need to go do it on your own. But if you
did enjoy, please give it a like and
subscribe and I'll see you guys next
time. Have a good one.